we're here in Scotland at the beautiful
world famous Loch Ness with a mission
with so much uncertainty in the world we
thought it was time to put one mystery
to rest that's why we're here to hunt
the Loch Ness monster we are gonna find
Nessie by any means necessary
[Music]
you know I had a dream that she appeared
really yeah yeah and she said to me
today is the day this is important
because the lower that you get is the
where the most monster is that's right
that's how you can tell it's saturated
and this is time and this is depth and
these are numbers now if you see here
this is a 12 36 and you still have not
had lunch lunch do feels like it feels
like you can bang that
absolutely Super Center finest today
it's been a pretty good day so far I
have found several
Messi's in the gift shop and I think as
long as that trend continues where we're
headed for the right outcome now one of
the tactics that you can use to get
Nessie to come out is to insult her it's
important to really stoke the fires of
Rage to make an appearance happen so I
think now what we can do is we can read
some inflammatory tweets that we've
prepared to really enrage the sea
monster of the lake a Nessie you old
lizard monster you're less spotted than
my dick
hey Nessie they say you're a monster but
I think you're just a big old bitch
you're never around and everyone has an
opinion about you who are you Rob
Kardashian yeah the weakest of the
Kardashians yeah it seems that insulting
wasn't maybe the best plan of action to
start with one thing that I know really
gets me out of the house is the fear of
missing out FOMO is the clinical term
let's give it a whirl let's give it a
try shall we
Wow it's a lot of fun up here above the
water Wow oh my gosh it's so great I
heard that Tom Hanks was coming oh my
god he's doing Forrest Gump start to
finish we did come around lunch time and
Nate our producer has not given us lunch
just yet okay sure all right so but it's
possible that Nessie herself is hungry
so what we've got here is some bread
that's you know it's a whole wheat bread
that she's probably watching her figure
from being a old bitch in the
lake yeah so we're gonna go ahead and
feed her Nessie is a creature that lives
in the water so do ducks ducks like
bread Nessie's gonna like bread one time
my great-uncle snuck into my room and
started throwing bread at me
when I was a child and I remember really
enjoying that and in a lot of ways this
is Nessie's room and where her
great-uncle
[Music]
nothing's worked so far but hopefully
we'll be able to think of something else
we're gonna consult with an expert to
try a few new things
[Music]
thank you so much for speaking with us
you know Brian and I have been trying to
find the Loch Ness monster and have
unfortunately been failing so um we're
so happy to speak to you would you
please introduce yourself and and we'll
start there look my name's Steve Felton
and I'm the current world champion at
the longest vigil hunting for the Loch
Ness monster so I've been sat here
watching and waiting for 27 years
do you remember what it's like to be
three and a half hours in pretty
exciting I find it at the beginning so
how do you spend your day watching love
this mm-hmm
what if she comes on the other end of
the lake I have long since will realize
that wherever I am is where Nessie is
not gonna be when you do catch Nessie
how do you plan on cooking it good
question
I haven't thought that far ahead maybe
like a tartar sauce or vinegar you know
Nessie burgers
are you a hundred percent sure that
Nessie's in the lock I am yes in and I'm
not saying it's gonna turn out to be the
dinosaur that everybody hopes there's
any number of different possibilities of
what Missy could actually turn out to be
a bigger duck massive duck a Bailey we
don't know if the jury's out as to what
the explanation is all we know is
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people keep seeing the back of something
so maybe what Nessie is is up to us
maybe not it would be up to Missy
wouldn't it it would be up to Missy what
Missy is yes is up to her
[Music]
thanks for watching that that was
starring the fantastic Ryan back in
Natasha ban blot directed by me Nate
there and we went to Scotland to make
that dumb little video and I think we
had a pretty good time
go call it dumb well you know do call it
little though silly silly unimportant
sure okay yeah and we made that for as a
part of our normal YouTube show every
damn day which is what you're watching
now and I think it turned out pretty
good I think yeah I think it's done
little video was was not so bad I don't
know if you guys felt this but in the
back of my mind a little bit I was like
but wait what if we are the ones really
I felt the same thing that like when you
play the lottery it's like statistically
you're not gonna win but when we were
throwing the bread that's what I however
like I was like I bet people haven't
tried the bread trick I really was like
oh this is so crazy but then when you
actually get out on the lock and you're
going through the boat and it's like
everybody there is like it's so excited
like maybe see something it's pretty
powerful place or just like something's
up here and it was like an overcast day
and you feel it's like so much deeper
and bigger you're like there's some sort
of message down so beautiful yeah what
what do you most miss about Scotland
everyone was nice to me there knowing
that no one demeaned your work really
nice
I missed the haggis really good dish
made of intestines right or like brought
in yes yeah you know what I miss is the
iron brew which is a soda its flavored
like bubblegum it's delicious
and it's the most popular soda in
Scotland it's the only country in the
world where the most popular soda isn't
like coca-cola or Pepsi it was just such
a beautiful country and I'd never been
out of the United States that's really
hadn't been let out this was the first
time what's cleared yeah yeah oh oh what
what should we what monster should we
hunt met
I think we should hunt gravy but only
because I love it whatever gets us sent
out of the country again oh cool maybe
well what about like Yeti or something
like that you go to the Himalayas yeah
absolutely
what's on the top of Kilimanjaro let's
invent a monster Oh - just like a
beautiful locale well you know in Hawaii
they have the Google muga no that's a
Park Slope food festival that's right
Matt by now fiancee at the googa ba Wow
well let us know in the comments which
monster you think we should hunt next
thanks so much for watching watch our
regular show every damn day please like
comment subscribe
[Music]